the entertainment industry suffered a
heavy blow
on friday august 28th 2020. when the
news broke that chadwick boseman
star of 42 21 bridges and most famously
marvel studios black panther died at the
age of 43.
he tragically succumbed to stage 4 colon
cancer which he'd bravely fought for
four years
and kept a secret from the public this
is a dark time for hollywood
fans and the entire world as one of its
most talented entertainers has left the
land of the living far too soon
as has become the norm when a big name
star passes away
many are now wondering what will become
of the projects bozeman was working on
prior to his untimely passing
regarding bozeman's completed work
there's one last hurrah on the way from
the de five bloods actor for fans to
enjoy while honoring his legacy
while his life ended unexpectedly we can
all still look forward to a final
outing with chadwick boseman boseman's
valiant battle against colon cancer
didn't stop him from seeing the
production of his last cinematic work to
the very end
directed by george c wolfe ma rainey's
black bottom
based on the play by august wilson
managed to finish principal photography
in 2019
and is currently in post-production for
the film's imdb page
in the film bozeman plays the role of a
trumpet player named levy who plays
opposite viola davis as legendary blues
singer ma
rainey ma rainey's black bottom is set
to hit netflix in 2020 but no exact date
is currently attached as of the making
of this video
in fact according to the hollywood
reporter netflix was planning on holding
a virtual preview of the film on monday
august 31st
but in the wake of bozeman's untimely
death those plans are currently on hold
additionally there's one more new
project in which fans can experience
bozeman's most popular role
black panther following his death
bozeman previously joined the ensemble
cast of marvel's what-if
animated series which centers around
alternate realities in the marvel
cinematic universe
to voice t'challa the only uncertainty
here is the extent to which he completed
his work on the show before he passed
away
what if we'll start streaming on disney
plus sometime in 2021